hallo leute hier ist wieder einmal bahn
und willkommen zu einer neuen folge ich
teste random schild aus der wellen bei
mir mein copilot timo rasch der aber
leider nicht vor die kamera möchte ganz
nach dem motto ich kaufe einen
supermarkt leer war ich heute beim asia
markt und habe mal alle rahmen nudeln
mitgenommen
interessant genug aussahen und die ich
noch nicht probiert hat bzw
ja einfach eine welle die auf
verschiedenste rahmen es sind natürlich
zehn stück zehn stück sind immer eine
schöne zahl und ich würde sagen wir
fangen mit tütensuppen nummer eins
einmal mit dem standard wir kennen die
umgehung bestimmt alle von frühjahr vom
schulhof oder vielleicht seid ihr heute
gerade auf dem schulhof gewesen und habe
natürlich um jungs verzehren wie haben
allerdings damit aufgehört weil
irgendwann mal das gerücht umging das
junge trocken oder ungekocht
krebserregend ist ich weiß bis heute
nicht ob diese information richtig ist
aber dann hab ich aufgehört juli um
trocken zu eng und ich glaube seitdem
habe ich auch keine jungen mehr gegessen
aber jetzt werden wir sich gucken schön
bei euch immer kochendes wasser
[Musik]
die damen kommen ist super kompliziert
also das haben wir sie finden und früher
dachte ich immer dieses öl ist voll
eklig jetzt weiß ich dass dadurch erst
der richtige geschmack zum vorschein
kommen er ist immer noch eklig und
sonders diese nimmt und mit heißem
wasser auf dieses buch ja und so kocht
man offiziell rahmen während wir warten
erzähle ich euch gerne davon dass ich
super gerne haben zurzeit esse aber auch
also die richtigen und diese typen
rahmen weil die so superschnell gehen
und immer diesen kleinen hunger oder
größeren hunger kurz weg machen
ich habe gekocht also ich bin so
gespannt ob ich mich an den
geschmacklichen das halt die gießener
jung jung ist einfach rahmen suchen
geschmack so sehen wir aus das ist
einmal vegetable ich meine kannten sich
auch selber dann so richtig geilen
fahren könnten mit so drauf und so und
ich finde diesen so perfekt für den
westlichen geschmack kann hat das gefühl
man ist was asiatisches dabei ist es
einfach nur eine standard gemüsebrühe
mit ein paar nudeln drin jetzt eine
bewertung sehen sind die geilsten rahmen
suppen tütensuppen die ich jemals
gegessen habe und 0 kann ich nicht essen
ich würde sagen ich gebe diesen rahmen
sieben von zehn jubeln
standard alles ist konserviert und
verstaut wollen jetzt ein bisschen crazy
sein als zweites essen wir die kind
schira die kommen natürlich aus korea
muss man leider sagen meine korea
obsession wird langsam weniger wie die
es läuft nur noch ab und zu und ich
spielt bei gc aber natürlich vier
minuten kochen
die medien machen 2000 jahre später
ich glaube ich auch ein bisschen zu viel
flüssigkeit gemacht der geruch ist sehr
gut liegt aber vielleicht immer noch
daran dass ich weder hunger haben damals
gut mir als erstes die brühe nach kohle
und stahl sowie kimchi fall vor die
schmecken ganz anders als die union
nudeln hier besser oh mein gott ich lag
auch da jetzt noch so ein halbes jahr
ein paar nori blättern kurven oder so
nur zu immer die schafe meter weiter
bestimmen ich überlege gerade ob diese
suppe schaaf ist ich bin sie herzlich
aber du bist da das sind anderen ratio
von schärfe dafür habe okay das schaf
also dem würde ich auf jeden fall acht
von zehn blut gegeben
kommen wir zur nächsten suppe
also ich hab vorher so exotisch wie man
so ne packung buchweizen tempura nudeln
aus japan
ich habe wirklich
also das ist ein tempura ich muss jetzt
kommen das wasser in unseren drei
minuten stehen lassen aus klappbrücke
heißes wasser ok einmal darauf also
jetzt geben wir einmal das heiße wasser
drauf und jetzt gute nacht wo es nicht
so gut wenn paar sekunden später o mein
gott her into you rief das kommt man so
wie das aus klasse manche sachen
brauchen einfach eine handy aufnahm also
aussehen tut schon okay
dieses tempura stelle war vor ihr habt
was frittiertes gehabt und habe es dann
in kochendes wasser eingelegt
ich bin zu tun stimmt hätte ich das
nicht reinlegen sollen sich dann hätte
dass ich mit gekommen sind
nein ich glaube ich hab's nicht gemacht
hast so lecker gewürzt ich raste aus
dass bekommen von mir
ziel von 10 schmeckt perfekt zu den
nächsten barbecue sleigh ride muss man
auch drei wochen kochen und sie kommen
aus indonesien das sind flight noodles
diesen freitodes geschmack haben
so riet das normal ist alles viel rad
gefahren
[Musik]
das sind meine indonesischen rahmen
nudeln die bisschen komisch riechen und
keine suppe haben begeistert bin ich
nicht aber jetzt mal wie amerika ist
mein gott ich wegen ganz anders die
steht mega und schmecken
also ich würde dem gibt den 1
sieben von zehn kugeln bekommen sie sind
auf jeden fall egger
ich werde jetzt eine pause machen und
morgen die zweite hälfte bzw
sechs übrigen packung essen wollen wurde
and happiness a6 rahmenbedingungen sind
noch vor uns ich träume immer noch von
diesen buchweizen nudeln mag wir hatten
die crazy indonesischen dann lasst uns
doch mal die hier auch indonesien reisen
wir nach taiwan und dort an ihr label
oliver klink mega ruhig mag auch so
französische zwiebelsuppe deswegen hoffe
ich das schmeckt irgendwie so ich kann
sie mir werden noch gerade nicht
vorstellen
die forscher kommen wir nun zu der
zubereitung
wow das ist ja neu ein blog mit
getrockneten nudeln das sieht aus wie
zwiebel schätzt glaubt dass es einfach
fan mit gerösteten und natürlich einmal
die suppe rühren sieht halt nicht
appetitlich aus lassen muss soll ich
habe das wasser um drauf also ich glaube
dass man das so macht wir haben jetzt
nicht geschrieben dass man es im topf
kochen soll aber auch nicht wie man es
machen soll
dirie nicht und zwiebel ich und sie wird
auch nicht so besonders aus es halt eine
zwiebelsuppe probieren erst die brühe
wenn mir das jemand so geben würde
durchdenken das einfach eine gemüsebrühe
ja ganz ehrlich sein bruder basic sich
jetzt nicht um ist aber auch nicht
täglich also voll angekommen so kommen
wir zu einem richtigen klassiker cup
nudeln sind die nummer eins in japan
japan und das ist ganz
man macht sich den deckel auf das hat so
einen schönen clean look muss ich sagen
und dann kippt man einfach nur ein
heißes wasser rein sieht schonmal gut
aus ich habe das gefühl dass ich eher
diese stereo kurpackung rieche als die
nudeln also ich habe ich das gefühl dass
ich das styropor schmeckt halt irgendwie
sehr ungewiss aber vielleicht wie man
zeigen mich die karten googles ich muss
sagen es schmeckt sehr fahrt kann
eigentlich verstehen warum das die
nummer eins in japan sein soll ein soll
das huhn geschmack sein
schmeck nächst was aber mega mit sich
ist dass der mais und diesel auf
zwiebeln
sie sehen so frisch aus und schmecken
relativ rasch solche vergessen die ihnen
zu bewerten den anderen den taiwan
onkels gebe ich selbst von zehn udl und
den gebe ich auch sechs von zehn abholen
weil ich habe das gefühl dass die nudeln
sich um die besser im mund anfühlt und
mundgefühl ist sehr wichtig beim essen
nächsten nudeln kommen wieder aus korea
und ich liebe den namen kategorien
blacksmith rostet
schaut euch dieses goldene engel
was ist das ein richtiges alles damit
machen sie auch auf der packung werbung
alles an charlie und die spv das so und
da kommt hält
da kommt doch nicht kelly sondern der
paketbote
[Musik]
also das sind richtige arzt im ehren
nudeln aber die sind richtig messi es
sind auch sicher keine spaghetti mit
asiatischen ich kann gerade nicht gut
beschreiben also es riecht lecker an
probleme noch mal ich bin jemand ich mag
es auch wenn es so sich gut im mund
anfühlt sich gut anhört und boa 10.10
nudeln wissen sie was ich manchmal denke
es gibt so viele leckere sachen auf der
welt und man probiert nicht mal ein
ansatz davon als nächstes problem wir
die schilder am nudel sie wollte einfach
meine damen probieren die scharf ist
aber nicht so 'oh mein gott dann kommen
wir mal zu gast und hier soll man nur
alles in den topf geben kochen und essen
statt kann ich da herausgekommen und
kelly muss noch unbedingt
die kritik der grünen
möglich aber dass fertige stunden
gestern ein barbecue ok als hemmnis für
welche partie aus korea
es ist ein wortspiel oder heiße zeit ich
dachte wie sting vielleicht etwas ab
ein bißchen geschmacklos irgendwie
schmeckt wirklich gar nicht krank ich
möchte noch nichts
so kommen wir zu der sammlung zwei siege
kenne ich schon die ganze das erste mal
richtig gekocht so schaffe ich habe viel
richtig scharf als letztes die zweimal
aber dies auch sehr scharfe die es
schafften das geld ab schafft dann
läuten tipp statt
das wasser rein machst das pulver mit
kokosmilch mischen und dann hast du so
eine prämie namen also die nudeln
lecker die konsistent sind so aber es
schon scharf die schafe kindheit den
ganzen geschmack dass es schmeckt nichts
außer nach scharfen ja da ist schon
lecker es ist eine grenze man findet es
schmerzhaft aber nicht so dass du jetzt
aufschließt und irgendwie ja gut aber
wenn wir es nicht so scharf
draußen fällt schon echt extrem scharfen
ja ich gebe der sieben weil die ist ja
lecker tut ihren job aber sie zeit zu
schaden kommen wir zum vorletzten
gesehen richtig cool adelige
aus vietnam für glas
also wir haben hühnerbrühe dann müssen
die köpfe runter stecken und suchen ist
es in der anderen seite aus dem mund
draußen ziel schlecker ich finde diese
nudeln tanzen in deinem mund so ein
bisschen selbstständig rom aber die
frühe es wird ein bisschen ist könnte
auch schon normale hühner so zu sein wie
gerührt
ja ich finde so und jetzt kommen wir zu
unseren finale mit hot rod laver rahmen
wurde sogar meine nase läuft
ich bin in zwei die für die komplette
eskalation dann ist meine nase wieder
frei da ist so ein feuer schweinchen und
[Musik]
alles rein wir machen komplett
wie machen die komplette klasse
dies trug alter so dunkel erwartet man
sie nicht richtig da sind bestimmt so
und in diese brühe sie zwar heftig aus
alltag ob man ja den los gehts na du
bist
ich bin sonst muss ich bin so ich hatte
das machen als ich erst mal die nudeln
leute da kommen die mainzer wenn ich die
brötchen langsam sagte hwk
ich habe extrem viele nudeln also so ja
ich glaube aber vielleicht ein bisschen
rot gerade ok ja da den gebe ich eine
vier von zehn mal dass uns die leute
machen wir sie zum schafe sind ja ja
dieses video einem dran geblieben sein
[Musik]
finger kribbelt falls ihr noch nicht
kennt sie hatten neuen kanal da ist
kanye west will ob du bist ein paar
jahren immer über kopf ich glaube meine
lieblings nudeln war auf jeden fall die
und also die sind weg ja das ist eine
mittelbare timo willst wie hits wie fire
fire fire du probieren hat dreimal
gerückt weil diese scharf sind so krank
und sterben auf die zum auf die zunge
[Applaus]
ich hoffe nicht dass ich hoffe kelly
unterbricht mich nicht noch da in meinem
leben denn sonst tödlichsten ich sie ja
damals mit wieder unterbrochen
die ja display an müssen jetzt
eigentlich